and i wish people in america understood
this and there's like oh beef we're
american beef i like beef yeah american
food
they don't know how to cook vegetables
puree yeah that's true that's true like
steamed broccoli that's [ __ ] like if
you talk this is what i would say like
she put in a pot asian cuisine knows how
to cook vegetables i could be vegetarian
if i made chinese indian cuisine like
some of my favorite food is indo-chinese
food which is very popular in india
really yeah they basically take uh
chinese cooking techniques and use like
indian spices also it's like southeast
asian style yeah like malaysian yeah
malaysia
it's also like malaysian food is very
because they get a lot of the influence
yeah yeah yeah yeah the sauces and the
breads and the cooking techniques and
it's like i love banana leaf at the
[ __ ] grove is there even a proper
indian fast food chain no not out here
at least because you're thinking about
jollibee weren't you filipino
what's the equivalent